[Music]
hello chilly chill whoops low right just
chilly Jordans yeah they glow in the
dark - they're kind of cool yeah that's
real cool these are the Jordan fives
yeah you know your numbers huh I have I
have a pair of Jordan five yeah they're
very flat though no arch support oh and
number one I do you ever feel like you
get grumpy in those kicks
um yeah my pinky toe usually hurting
them cuz I always get the night and a
half when I really wear a 10 cuz it may
look too big on me so my pinky toe is
pretty bad wait I'm sorry you usually
get the 9 and a half yeah but I'm a
really a 10 yeah that's like some lady
[ __ ] I know you think a 10 looks too big
yeah so I get denied a half what does it
10 look like a corrective boot man I'm
only like 5 8 at least that's what I
tell people really like five six five
six I'll put on a size 10 it looked like
a size 12 you know what I'm saying I
think so
you just got a lot of a lot of
manipulation and lies happening what is
going on you're like a cool you're a hip
hopper yeah you got you got the hit
music people ladies must love you even
really I do you always tell me to cut my
facial hair
q who are these hoes
they actually told me that we probably
have similar taste in in the ladies yeah
I like I like a thicker milkshake yeah
yeah I like my borderline fat I find
they respond better to thicker milkshake
[Applause]
[Music]